a new gallup poll suggests that going to
prestigious colleges doesn't actually
make us any happier in life or and work
this comes from a survey of 29,000
college graduates by purdue university
and let's look at findings five and six
report doing great in at least one
sphere a sense of purpose financial
security physical health close
relationships or community pride only
eleven percent are thriving in all five
areas of well-being and the percentages
did not vary based on whether the grads
went to a top 100 school in the US News
and World Report rankings or one of the
bottom 100 so this is kind of
interesting because we put so much
emphasis on going to the right college
no matter how much it costs and
apparently it cost a lot these days I
went to a new york state school SUNY
Binghamton which is perfectly fine
school pretty good academic school I
smoked a lot of hot there there's stuff
I studied politics so I guess something
translated into my life now does this
surprise you or not surprise you that
going to these better schools isn't
actually equated to any sort of bigger
sense of fulfillment in life it's
surprising to NPR things that that uh
you know academia is the end-all be-all
yeah yeah it's not surprising me because
well first of all Purdue also is full of
miserable people i'm from diana and
that's why you would probably think that
if you're right well the study way by
Purdue what was he I think a little bit
of a little tampering might have gone on
there so they were just trying to lose a
little shout that's right got it um no I
didn't go to college in the traditional
sense yeah meaning I didn't go to
college I went for him about a year and
a half well I did not know did not I
tell you that doesn't changes and I got
lucky that I am working in an industry
where it doesn't necessarily you don't
have to go to college to work in
television but a lot of talking about
you're talking about things that are
important I know I just discredited my
entire self but you know you can read a
lot they access information it's like I
went to college with a lot of kids we
hire a lot of college kids and they're
really dumb they're like drunk they have
the sheepish marked mentality that like
sorry sorry guys yeah but uh you know
it's
just I think that at least to me as I've
gotten in my older my later 20s I
realized that it's a lot less important
but where you went to school and more
about like what you can actually do in a
daily basis and how like connected you
are with knowledge yeah yeah what does
this say about our college system
because you'd like to think that if you
go to a good school you will get a good
job you will have more money you will
somehow be happier I think that's sort
of the theme in America that that's or
how it's going to work and yet we're
finding out that that I think it's
wonderful I think it's fabulous I'm glad
to hear this because you know so many of
the people that I've met you know just
from just all walks who are talking
you'll talk about how oh you know you
had to go to a prestigious university if
you wanted to get into this escalon of
society and if that means that you can
still be happy and still have a
fulfilling career and still do work that
you think is important than satisfaction
satisfactory to you then it's wonderful
that you can go to just a regular old
state school and still be able to
achieve those things you know one of the
things that they don't talk about in
this particular study is about the
network that you get from going to an
elite universities so I think that can
have a very large impact on your ability
to get a job right out of graduation and
the industry of your choice but beyond
that if it doesn't make you happier I
think that that's really a boost to
everybody who who wants to go to college
and then feels like they're somehow
starting off at a deficit because they
didn't go to an elite University yeah is
this also part of this thing that that
college is people are talking about this
now that colleges are pricing themselves
out of relevance that people we don't
have a great economy obviously people
can't afford to go to these places
anymore and then they're finding out the
college graduates aren't getting the
jobs that they used to get so his
colleges like just a general thing
becoming somewhat obsolete I mean if you
ask me and you're coming from the guy
yeah and the reason I didn't go was
because I had used college as a way to
open a bunch of doors where I could like
work my ass off and have opportunities
that it happened way sooner than I had
actually planned on that was like for me
you know to work with with Larry King it
was like I couldn't pass up that
opportunity to have that happen right so
it was like I probably would have
continued to go to school I just got
really lucky and you know I have the
idea that like for the pursuit of
knowledge
I would probably go back someday if this
whole thing goes away sir well you know
there are issues with the you know in
some places like if you need to get a
job in a in a regular industry not
another statement or yeah joke a joke I
mean more like if you need to get a job
in an engineering field and you must
have that if you want to work in one of
these other you know capacities you must
have a degree so knowing that it's
actually possible is pretty cool but you
know remember there's a student loan
crisis as well and I think that also
negatively impacts people's happiness
and satisfaction later on when you are I
don't know struggling under a crushing
debt so you're saying if you went to a
prestigious college and then you got out
of it you were a hundred thousand
dollars in that it might affect you or a
general state of well-being yeah you
might be a little less happy about stuff
you know but there was a good point in
that article and in that specific study
about how good teachers good teachers
and good mentors really made a big
difference in those people that reported
high satisfaction so I think that that
is a great Avenue to to look at you know
how do we get better teachers you know
because if people are satisfied with
their lives 10 20 years on because they
had a teacher who cared about them it
was a really good teacher you know I
think that that shows one a great Avenue
for which you know through which we can
create you know better outcomes for
people focusing on the teachers and the
mentoring and sometimes you can get that
teacher in high school doesn't have
right from college but good teachers
being being this this launching point
for a good life I think that's really
neat